Der Aufbau der Segelflugkarte.
Wie gesagt, wenn man so auf einen Blick drauf schaut, will man die Karte am liebsten gleich wieder zu tun.
Es gibt fast ein bisschen Angstgefühl.
Einmal bei mir zumindest war es so am Anfang, als ich mich mit dem auseinandergesetzt habe.
Wenn man aber den Aufbau von Grund auf einmal anschaut und alle diese Kästchen rauspickt
und nachher wieder in die Karte legt, dann ist es gerne so wahnsinnig kompliziert.
Dann weiss man mal grundsätzlich, was welches Kästchen und welche Linie bedeutet.
Und nachher sind es einfach wahnsinnig viele übereinander gestachtelt.
Und manchmal ist es noch schwierig zu herausfinden, welche Linie gehört jetzt zu welchem Luftraum.
Aber das ist dann mehr auch ein optisches Problem.
Also das Verständnis für die Karte möchte ich euch probieren, um jetzt hier ein bisschen aufzuzeigen
und von Grund auf die Karte aufzubauen.
So, als erste markante Linie ist die Trennlinie vom Mittelland und vom Jura.
Und von den Alpen.
Die erstreckt sich eigentlich quer durch die Schweiz, wie ihr hier seht.
Ungefähr beim Genfersee, bei Montreux, geht die quer durch die Zentralschweiz
bis zu uns in die Alpsteinregion und nachher über Richtung Österreich.
Und so wird die Schweiz dann unterteilt.
Und das hat einfach einen topografischen Hintergrund,
dass im Jura und im Mittelland natürlich alle Berge viel tiefer sind
und in den Alpen ein bisschen höher.
Und da sind die Lufträume ein bisschen...
viel höher hoch geschoben worden.
Und das hat dann auch einen Einfluss auf uns als Gleitschirmpiloten.
Zu dem kommen wir nämlich gleich jetzt.
Wie gesagt, das G und das E werden wir ja jederzeit befliegen.
Beim C und beim D brauchen wir eine Bewilligung.
Und das G könnt ihr euch jetzt einfach mal vorstellen,
der blaue Balken, wie ein Teppich, der über die ganze Schweiz,
über die ganze Topografiekarte geleitet wird.
Und der Teppich ist 600 Meter hoch.
Und der Übergang...
Nachher über diese 600 Meter,
dort geht es ins E rüber.
Dort dürfen wir immer noch fliegen.
Es ist einfach ein anderer Luftraum mit anderen Regeln.
Für uns als Gleitschirmpiloten können wir aber in beide hineinfliegen.
Nachher wird es für uns interessant.
Nämlich wo ist die Grenze, wo es nämlich vom E ins C rüber geht
und wir nicht mehr weiter fliegen dürfen.
Wo wir auch bei Superthermik irgendwann sagen müssen,
okay, ich bin jetzt zwar in einem Schlauch, der würde noch weiter steigen,
die Wolkenbasis ist erst höher oben,
aber wir müssen aus diesem Schlauch raus und schauen,
dass wir nicht ins C hineinkommen.
Und dort wird es dann eben spannend und auch sehr wichtig,
dass wir wissen, wo diese Grenze ist.
Im Jura seht ihr, also alles was links ist von diesem Querschnitt,
ist diese Grenze bei 3050 Meter.
In den Alpen ist diese Grenze bei 4550 Meter.
Also ihr seht, wir haben hier schon einen ziemlichen Unterschied von der Höhe
und natürlich auch von den Möglichkeiten, die wir haben mit dem Gleitschirm.
Ganz wichtig ist noch zu wissen, jetzt angenommen,
dieser Berg hier wäre 4200 Meter hoch,
dann dürfen wir hier trotzdem 600 Meter drüber.
Also dann könnte man jetzt in diesem Fall bis auf 4800 Meter drüber fliegen
und deutlich über diese 4550 Meter.
Die Voraussetzung ist einfach, dass ihr nie mehr als 600 Meter Bodenabstand habt.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Jetzt haben wir hier von diesen 4550 geredet.
Da ist ganz wichtig zu wissen,
das gilt nur, wenn das Militär nicht aktiv ist,
wenn das Militär nicht in der Luft ist und nicht am Trainieren ist.
Und wenn das Militär nämlich unterwegs ist und fliegt,
oben links seht ihr «Mill on»,
dann passiert nämlich etwas mit dieser Grenze,
die kommt nämlich oben runter auf 3950 Meter.
Darunter seht ihr noch die Militärzeiten eingeblendet,
die sind auch auf der Segelflugkarte drauf
und ganz wichtig einzuhalten.
Also das ist immer vom Montag bis Freitag,
von halb acht bis fünf ab zwölf
und vom Viertel ab eins bis fünf ab fünf.
Diese fünf Minuten sind einfach zum Überschneiden auszuschliessen,
damit es da sicher keine Kollisionen oder Zwischenfälle gibt.
Also ganz wichtig, wenn das Militär aktiv ist,
dann kommt diese Grenze in den Alpen etwas oben runter,
ist aber immer noch deutlich höher als im Jura und im Mittelland.
Also hier nochmal schnell zum Überblick.
Der Übergang vom E bis C erfolgt im Mittelland,
bei 3050.
In den Alpen variiert es eben je nach Aktivität des Militärs.
Einen kleinen Punkt habe ich hier noch vergessen,
bei all diesen Lufträumen.
Der Luftraum D, der ja auch kontrolliert ist
und wo wir auch eine Freigabe ohne Funkkontakt brauchen,
der kommt vor allem in der Nähe von Flugplätzen zur Anwendung.
Also wir haben das G, den Teppich, der drübergelegt ist,
nachher kommt das E und darüber das C
und das D kommt dann vor allem über Flugplätze.
Zum Zug.
Dann sind alle diese Lufträume mit sogenannten Tags kennzeichnet.
Das seht ihr jetzt hier links einmal in der Theorie
und rechts, wie es dann auf der Karte aussieht.
Und diese Tags haben immer eine Untergrenze und eine Obergrenze.
Dort ist noch ganz wichtig, dass ihr den Unterschied seht
zwischen geraden Zahlen und kursiven Zahlen.
Wenn es gerade ist, ist es über Grund,
wenn es kursiv geschrieben ist, ist es über Meer.
Und der zweite grosse Unterschied, den ihr jetzt hier bei diesen Zahlen seht,
ist, dass die Oberzahl blau hinterlegt ist.
Eine blau hinterlegte Zahl bedeutet,
dass es die Höhe nach der Standardatmosphäre ist.
Jetzt seht ihr, wie im Gleitschirmsport oder in der Gleitschirmtheorie
auch immer alle diese Themen ein wenig miteinander verwandt sind
und irgendwo ineinander reingreifen.
Beim Meteo habt ihr schon viel über die Standardatmosphäre gehört.
Hier geht es genau auch wieder darum,
dass der Standarddruck angenommen wird.
Somit ist die weissgeschriebene Zahl die effektiv höhere,
also wenn ihr die GPS-Messung anschaut
oder eine Tafel auf einem Berg oben mit den Höhenangaben,
also wirklich die effektive, die scharfe Kante.
Die blau hinterlegte Zahl ist dann die Zahl,
die je nach Wetter auch schwanken kann,
weil man einfach die Druckmessung auf Meereshöhe rechnet
und einfach immer davon ausgeht,
auf Meereshöhe ist der gleiche Druck,
nämlich die 1013.25 Hektopascal.
Und wieso das genau so ist,
probiere ich euch jetzt in den nächsten Folien
ein wenig näher zu bringen.
Die Höhe messen wir ja basierend auf einer Druckmessung.
Das heisst, euer Gerät misst
einen gewissen Druck,
ausser wir haben natürlich eine Höhenmessung mit GPS,
aber ein standardmässiges Höhegerät,
das den Druck misst,
ordnet einen gewissen Druck zu einer gewissen Höhe.
Und dieser Druck schwankt aber jeden Tag.
Auf einem Berggipfel,
auf dem Sentis zum Beispiel,
herrscht nicht jeden Tag der gleiche Druck,
der schwankt täglich.
Und somit müsste man eigentlich
so einen Höhenmesser jedes Mal vor dem Start kalibrieren,
auf die Starthöhe einstellen,
damit er dann auch an diesem Tag stimmt.
Jetzt ist es aber auch so,
im Verlauf des Tages kann der Druck ja auch mal ein wenig wechseln
und dann kann am Abend nach der Landung
der Höhenmesser schon wieder um ein paar Meter verfälscht sein.
Und dafür hat man jetzt eine Lösung gefunden.
Und diese Lösung heisst eben Flight Levels,
Flugflächen.
Und das kommt aus der internationalen Fliegerei.
Weil ja Flugzeuge,
die von einem Ort zum anderen
über weitere Distanzen fliegen,
auch verschiedene Wetterzonen
und verschiedene Druckgebiete durchfliegen.
Und das würde ja bedeuten,
dass man eigentlich den Höhenmesser
an ein paar Metern oder an ein paar Kilometern Flug
neu kalibrieren müsste,
neu auf den Bodendruck einstellen müsste.
Man müsste irgendwie immer wieder funken,
wie ist hier das Wetter,
wie ist hier der Druck am Boden,
dass diese Höhe stimmt.
Und das wäre natürlich fast unmöglich
und extrem aufwendig.
Und es würde eben auch das Risiko bergen,
dass man dann vielleicht gleich einen Berechnungsfehler macht
oder vielleicht die Druckschwanke gleich gleich wechselt
und dass es dann Zusammenstösse gibt.
Und darum hat man sich in der Fliegerei geeinigt,
dass man eben nicht nach effektiven Höhen fliegt,
sondern nach Standarddruck.
Der Standarddruck, wie gesagt,
bei 1013,25 Hektopascal auf Meereshöhe.
Und jetzt habe ich hier noch ganz schnell ein Rechnungsbeispiel,
bevor wir dann nochmal auf die Flight Levels eingehen
und wie es in der Praxis funktioniert.
Einfach, dass ihr euch mal ein bisschen vorstellen könnt,
was das bedeutet.
Also das Beispiel mit Flight Level 100.
Ein Flight Level sind 100 Fuss.
Das heisst, Flight Level 100 sind 10'000 Fuss.
Und weil ein Fuss 30,48 cm hoch ist,
ist dann eben Flight Level 100 3'048 Meter.
Und so sehen wir wieder die Verbindung
oder können wir uns erklären,
wieso das zum Beispiel im Jura
das Level oder der Luftraum C bei 3'050 Meter beginnt.
Das ist nämlich Flight Level 100
und kommt aus der Linienfliegerei heraus.
Und genau so ist es in den Alpen.
Die 3'950 sind nämlich Flight Level 130
und die 4'550 sind Flight Level 150.
Und in der unteren Lage ist es natürlich wichtig,
dass ein Flugzeug nach den exakten Höhen fliegen kann.
Einfach auch wegen der Topografie,
dass es keine Kollisionen mit Bergen gibt
oder mit Hindernissen.
Aber an einer gewissen Höhe spielt es gerne nicht mehr so eine Rolle,
ob die Flieger sich so kreuzen
oder ein bisschen weiter unten sich so kreuzen.
Das Wichtigste ist einfach,
dass die Flieger separiert sind
und nicht auf der gleichen Höhe fliegen.
Und das hat man dann eben mit dem Flight Level
eigentlich angebracht.
Weil ihr seht, wenn jetzt ein Flieger
von einem Hoch in einen Tief hineinfliegt,
da muss nicht so eine extreme Kurve sein natürlich,
das ist jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben dargestellt,
aber dann schwankt der Flight Level immer ein bisschen.
Also der Flieger schwimmt immer so ein bisschen,
geht mal ein bisschen hoch, mal ein bisschen runter.
Aber er ist immer auf dem gleichen Druck,
also er fliegt genau auf der gleichen Druckfläche.
Und dann spielt es gerne nicht so eine Rolle,
ob er auf 11'000 oder auf 10'900 ist.
Wichtig ist, dass die Flieger auf verschiedenen Levels fliegen.
Und dass sie so eine Kollision vermeiden können.
Anwendung in den Segelflugkarten
hat es vor allem bei den TMAs und bei den Airways.
Zu dem kommen wir gerne später,
wie die aufgebaut sind.
Aber einfach, wenn ihr euch hier nochmal die Tags anschaut,
mit dem D, Luftraum D,
die haben immer eine Unterkante.
Hier ist es jetzt der Boden, Ground.
Hier haben wir auch eine Unterkante von 2'250 und 2'600.
Und die ist fix.
Da ist es hier ganz wichtig,
dass die fix ist, wegen der Topografie.
Das ist jetzt hier beim Beispiel von Meiringen,
wo es ja links und rechts sehr hohe Berge hat.
Die Obergrenze, die 3'950,
dort sind wir dann eben wieder in dem Bereich,
wo es gar keine Rolle spielt,
weil es kein Hindernis mehr hat.
Diese Höhe kann dann schwanken.
Und das ist jetzt auf dieser Folie nochmal ein bisschen erklärt.
Also ihr seht, wir haben hier eine Topografie.
Diese Unterkante ist sehr scharf,
weil wenn diese hier druckbasiert schwanken würde,
dann hätten wir hier ein Problem.
Dann würde auf einmal so eine TMA,
so eine Anflugschneise,
nämlich in eine Bergtopografie reinlaufen
und könnte eine Kollision verursachen.
Die Obergrenze, die schwankt dann aber.
Und wie viel das hier ausmacht,
seht ihr hier.
Das ist auch noch interessant,
um zu wissen, wenn wir am Gleitschirm fliegen sind.
Da ist übrigens auch auf der Segelflugkarte drauf,
diese Zahlen.
Also ihr seht,
bei 1'037 Hektopascal,
Bodendruck.
Und das ist schon,
also abgerechnet der Bodendruck,
das ist natürlich schon sehr hoch,
ein starkes Hoch.
Und dort macht es etwa 200 Meter aus.
Wiederum in einem sehr tiefen Tiefdruckgebiet
macht es minus 200 Meter.
Also es ist schon relativ viel.
Was man noch dazu sagen kann,
bei so einem tiefen Druck sind wir wahrscheinlich nicht am Fliegen,
im Normalfall,
weil es einfach ganz schlechtes Wetter ist
und Sturm angesagt ist.
Bei einem extrem hohen Hoch sind wir,
machen wir vielleicht einen Gleitflug
von einem hochalpinen Berg,
aber wahrscheinlich auch weniger einen Thermikflug,
weil es einfach schon wieder zu stabil ist.
Jetzt kommen wir schon wieder ein bisschen
in die Wetterkunde hinein.
Aber meistens sind wir ja so ein bisschen im Bereich
von vielleicht plus,
vielleicht einmal sogar 100 Meter
in der Luft am Thermikfliegen.
Und das Gute ist dann,
dass ja diese Grenzen vor allem gegen hoch wandern.
Also wenn ihr wisst,
oben ist ein Luftraum,
der bei 3'050 anfängt
und ihr seid am Thermikflug,
ist es meistens so,
dass der eher ein bisschen höher ist.
Aber das ist natürlich eben dann genau wichtig,
dass das Gerät richtig eingestellt ist
und dass wir dann dort nicht reinfliegen.
Danach zur Abwechslung einmal eine Prüfungsfrage,
die auch auf euch zukommen könnte,
an der Gleitschirmtheorieprüfung.
Da seht ihr jetzt,
die Obergrenze des Luftraums Klasse E
über den Jura ist gefragt.
Dann müsst ihr euch zum ersten Mal Gedanken machen,
ja wie hoch wäre es denn normal?
Jura, haben wir gesagt,
ist egal, ob es militäraktiv oder inaktiv ist,
ist die Obergrenze für uns bei 3'050.
Jetzt haben wir ein sehr starkes Hoch.
Auf den ersten Blick sieht man viele Zahlen
und hat jetzt das Gefühl,
oh wow, was muss ich jetzt genau berechnen und so.
Aber eigentlich,
es wird nicht verlangt,
dass ihr Berechnungen durchführen könnt.
Ihr müsst einfach sehen,
hey, das ist ein wahnsinnig starkes Hoch.
Bei einem sehr starken Hoch
macht es maximal ungefähr 200 Meter.
Und hier seht ihr dann schnell,
3'9 oder 4'1 wäre natürlich viel, viel zu viel.
Also so viel macht es dann nicht aus.
Es macht eben in einem Rahmen von plus minus 200 Meter etwas aus,
falls eine solche Prüfungsfrage auf euch zukommt.
Jetzt haben wir einen kleinen Ausflug gemacht
Richtung Flight Level.
Ja, leicht abgeschweift von der Segelflugkarte,
was aber glaube ich auch nötig war
für das Verständnis,
wie die Lufträume aufgebaut sind.
Ich hoffe,
es hat euch ein wenig geholfen.
Jetzt kommen wir wieder zurück
zu den weiteren Lufträumen.
Hier ist jetzt der Luftraum D,
den ich vorhin kurz angesprochen habe.
Das sind die CTRs,
die Kontrollzonen,
die gleich in unmittelbarer Nähe
von den grossen Flughafen sind.
Und die gehen immer vom Boden
bis auf eine gewisse Höhe.
Die Höhe und auch die Form
ist natürlich sehr topografieabhängig
und auch abhängig von den Anflugschneisen
und vom Bedarf von diesem Flughafen.
Und die sind natürlich nicht immer rund.
Das ist jetzt nur symbolisch dargestellt.
Darüber kommen dann die TMAs,
DNA-Kontrollbezirke.
Ihr könnt euch auch wieder vorstellen,
wie so Schachteln aufeinandergestellt werden.
Bei den TMAs gibt es noch etwas Spezielles.
Also hier zum Beispiel eine CTR.
Dann habt ihr eine TMA,
wo eigentlich die Box so in einen Berg reinläuft
oder in eine Topografie reinläuft.
Das gibt es manchmal.
Und hier ist noch ganz wichtig zu wissen,
dass ihr mit dem Gleitschirm
aber Achtung nur südlich von der Trennlinie
Mittelland-Alpen, also nur in den Alpen,
300 Meter drunter rausfliegen werdet.
Das gibt es in ganz wenigen Fällen.
Das ist auch eine Prüfungsfrage,
die ein bisschen tricky ist,
wo man reinkommen könnte.
Passet auf mit diesen 300 Metern.
Es gibt natürlich Startplätze,
wo man jetzt zum Beispiel hier startet
und super schön unter diesen 300 Metern
hier unten rausfliegen kann
und jederzeit absolut legal im Rahmen ist.
Und auch keine Bewilligung dafür braucht.
Dann haben wir noch die Luftstrasse.
Die verbindet dann eben die grösseren Flughafen
und auch die Hauptverbindungsachsen
des internationalen Luftverkehrs.
Hier nochmal eine kleine Ansicht von der Seite.
Ihr seht, es kann mehrere TMAs haben.
Es kann fünf, sechs, sieben TMAs haben.
Es kann nur eine sein.
Das ist ganz unterschiedlich.
Und wie gesagt,
kommt ganz auf den Flugverkehr
und auf die Topografie des Flughafens an.
Die Aktivität dieser TMAs
und dieser CTRs kann auch unterschiedlich sein.
Wenn 9 steht,
also wir haben hier die Bezeichnung CTR LSZR,
wenn jetzt 9 steht,
dann ist sie permanent aktiv,
wie zum Beispiel in Zürich bei den grossen Flughafen.
Wenn es HX ist,
dann hat sie keine fixen Betriebszeiten,
muss aber grundsätzlich davon ausgehen,
dass sie jederzeit aktiv ist
und man den Status abfragen kann.
Und dann gibt es noch die temporären.
Die temporären würden dann über das DAPS bekannt gegeben,
wann diese aktiv sind.
Da gibt es in der Schweiz nur zwei Fälle,
SIO und Alpnach.
Zu diesem Beispiel kommen wir dann nachher noch.
Es gibt diese drei Aktivitätsstatus von TMAs und CTRs.
Wir haben in der Schweiz einen ganzen Haufen Heliports.
Die sind so eingezeichnet.
Und wir müssen einen Radius von zweieinhalb Kilometern
zu diesen einhalten.
Kleinere Flugplätze ohne CTRs sind so eingezeichnet.
Die haben einen Radius von fünf Kilometern,
wo wir Abstand halten müssen.
Hier haben wir noch eine kleine Zusammenfassung.
Hier im Raum Luzern,
das ist so ein bisschen das Bermuda-Dreieck für uns
Gleitschirmpiloten,
wo wir wirklich ganz gut schauen müssen,
dass wir niemandem in den Luftraum reinkommen.
Aber ein ganz schönes Fluggebiet.
Und man kann durchaus auch fliegen,
auch wenn es jetzt hier sehr, sehr komplex aussieht.
Hier drauf seht ihr gleich alle Beispiele,
die es gibt.
Also es gibt den Heliport mit zweieinhalb Kilometern,
den Zivilflugplatz.
Dann gibt es gemischte Flugplätze,
die militärisch und zivil verwendet werden.
Und dann gibt es rein militärische Flugplätze,
die dann so rot umkreiselt sind.
Noch interessant ist,
es geht dann nur auf 600 Meter über den Grund.
Also man könnte dort mit über 600 Metern drüber fliegen,
ohne dass man da Probleme bekommen würde.
Zu diesem Thema ist es noch wichtig,
wenn ihr irgendwo einen Streckenflug geplant habt
und das Gefühl habt,
da geht meine Idealflugroute und die Thermik
und der Winkel des Geländes und so,
meine Route geht eigentlich genau dort durch
oder würde gerade so knapp den Heliport kratzen,
dann ist es sicher Zeit wert,
schnell dem nachzugehen
und beim SAV bei diesen lokalen Vereinbarungen
zu schauen, ob es vielleicht bei diesem Heliport
sogar eine lokale Abmachung gibt.
Wenn ihr keine weiteren Infos habt,
dann müsst ihr immer davon ausgehen,
es sind zweieinhalb Kilometer Radius
und fünf Kilometer Radius bei den Flugplätzen
und 600 Meter.
Vielleicht ist es aber wie jetzt hier zu Trogen,
wo so ein Spickel abgeschnitten ist,
wo man durchaus auch durch die Tour fliegt.
Und zudem seht ihr,
dass jetzt hier Ground bis 1200 Meter steht.
Trogen ist aber etwa auf 800-900 Meter.
Das heisst, es sind auch deutlich weniger als 600 Meter.
Und das kann einem sehr weiterhelfen,
nachher in der Praxis,
wenn man eben so etwas Zusatzinformationen hat.
Dann haben wir auf der Segelflugkarte
auch Hindernisse eingezeichnet.
Die sehen dann ungefähr so aus.
Hier das Beispiel vom Sentis.
Wir haben das Hindernis.
Oben steht, dass es ein Licht hat.
Das ist dann eher für die Flugzeuge wichtig,
die in der Nacht unterwegs sind,
dass es beleuchtet ist.
Für uns jetzt weniger interessant.
Für uns ist es auch noch spannend,
die Höhe zu sehen.
Und hier kommt es zum Zug
mit der kursiven Schrift und der geraden Schrift.
Kursiv geschrieben heisst über Meer.
Das ist also die Spitze der Antenne.
Und die 124 Meter, die Geradschrift,
so hoch ist die Antenne effektiv.
Also man weiss,
okay, die Antenne ist so gross,
dass ich sie von Weitem sehen soll.
Es gibt uns einfach ein wenig einen Anhaltspunkt.
Wichtig sind auch noch die Seile,
die eingezeichnet sind.
Mit diesen 100 und 264 Metern
gibt es einfach den höchsten Abstand über dem Boden an.
Also auch hier könnt ihr ein wenig abschätzen,
wie gross diese Seile sind.
Ganz wichtig,
passt auf,
nicht jedes Hindernis
ist auf der Segelflugkarte eingezeichnet.
Es gibt viele Hindernisse,
die hier nicht drin sind.
Dazu solltet ihr die Luftfahrtshinderniskarte
noch anschauen.
Und auch wenn ihr diese abgeklärt habt,
fliegt mit offenen Augen.
Fliegt nicht einfach blind irgendwo rein,
weil es kann immer sein,
dass irgendwo ein Holz- oder Heusseil hängt,
das gesetzlich gesehen nicht eingetragen sein muss.
Und das könnt ihr auch zum Verhängnis wehren.
Darum immer mit offenen Augen fliegen
und auch mit den Locals reden.
Und bei den Clubs und Vereinen
und auch bei den Talstationen der Bahnen
findet man meistens auch ganz gute Infos
zu solchen Luftfahrtshindernissen.
Also zu diesem Thema nicht hundertprozentig
nur auf die Segelflugkarte schauen.
Von diesen sieht man ja auch ganz viele.
Die LSRs, die roten.
Die roten Rs
die sind Restricted.
Also dort dürfen wir nicht reinfliegen.
Auf der Segelflugkarte sind die,
die ganz häufig aktiv sind,
eingezeichnet.
Und nachher wiederum gehen wir in das Tabs rein
am Vorabend, um zu schauen,
ob das jetzt auch aktiv ist an dem Tag,
an dem ich fliegen will oder nicht.
Dann gibt es noch die LST.
Das ist nicht Restricted.
Das ist Danger.
Da könnt ihr grundsätzlich reinfliegen.
Es wird einfach nicht empfohlen,
weil gefährliche Vorgänge stattfinden können.
Wie Schiessübungen zum Beispiel.
Am Boden unten.
Und dass man dann gleich in den Luftraum reinfliegen darf.
Ist natürlich nicht empfohlen.
Aber grundsätzlich nicht gesetzlich verboten.
Hier haben wir gleich ein Beispiel von so einer LSR.
Bei uns in der Region.
Über dem Alpstein und dem Walasee.
Der LSR 3.
Und hier seht ihr jetzt auch wieder
die Untergrenzen und die Obergrenzen.
Die sind jetzt so rot-hinderlight.
Und das bedeutet wieder,
dass die ganze Atmosphäre rot ist.
Und dass die ganze Box des Trainingsraums
des Militärs schwanken kann.
Der kann mal etwas höher sein
oder mal etwas tiefer sein.
Hier noch ein bisschen besser angezeichnet,
damit man ihn gut sieht.
Eine kleine Erklärung zum DABS.
Das DABS findet ihr auf www.skybriefing.com
Gerade als ersten Input ganz wichtig.
Schaut immer, dass das Datum stimmt.
Weil wenn ihr für den falschen Tag schaut
und das Gefühl habt,
dass ihr überall rein fliegt
und an dem Tag, an dem ihr unterwegs seid,
irgendwelche Schiessübungen stattfinden,
ist das natürlich sehr ungünstig.
Schaut immer, dass das Datum stimmt.
Hier seht ihr auf dieser Karte
die rot einzeichneten LSRs
sind nicht gross verbreitet.
Es sind nicht sehr viele aktiv.
Dieser bei uns im Alpstein ist auch nicht aktiv.
Das heisst nicht, dass diese immer aktiv sein müssen,
nur weil sie auf der Segelflugkarte sind.
Das sind einfach die,
die sehr häufig benutzt werden.
Weil sie dort permanent auf der Karte sind.
Aber am Tag selber müsst ihr
immer im DABS schnell nachschauen.
Ich habe hier als Beispiel das D12 herausgenommen.
Bei Eisidlen in der Nähe.
Hier hat man natürlich
sehr wenige Infos darüber.
Und unten in der Legende
sieht man dann, wenn
und wie hoch
dieser Raum gesperrt ist.
Oder eben als Danger Area
deklariert wird.
Und auch was hier hinten gemacht wird.
Hier empfehle ich auch,
schaut einfach ab und zu mal rein.
Auch wenn ihr vielleicht mal nicht fliegen geht
und gerade an diesem Tag im Büro seid.
Schaut kurz rein.
Es ist manchmal spannend, was man noch alles entdeckt.
Und hier ist noch
extrem wichtig, dass ihr auf die Zeit schaut.
Es ist nämlich UTC.
Bei UTC
das ist die Standardzeit.
Da müssen wir im Winter eine Stunde
zu rechnen, Schweizer Zeit.
Und im Sommer 2 Stunden zu rechnen,
bis wir die Aktivzeit haben.
Also wenn jetzt hier steht,
es ist ab 7.00 Uhr aktiv,
dann ist es im Sommer erst ab 9.00 Uhr aktiv.
Je nachdem kann es gut sein für uns.
Oder es kann uns dann eben auch nicht entgegenkommen.
Und unsere Flugzeit etwas verkürzen,
die wir dort durchfliegen.
Wie es der Zufall wollte,
ist jetzt auf dieser,
in diesem DABS,
die temporäre TMA von SIO
aktiv gewesen.
Das sieht man nicht sehr häufig,
aber ist super, um zu zeigen,
die drei Aktivitätszustände,
welche eine TMA
oder CTR haben kann.
SIO und ALPNACH
wie gesagt, die einzigen, welche
über das DABS kommuniziert werden.
Und hier sieht man jetzt gerade,
wie diese dann aussehen.
In der Segelflugkarte,
es ist ein ganz feines Detail.
Man sieht es fast nicht,
aber die Umrahmung ist etwas feiner.
Darum ist diese TMA
etwas anders zu behandeln, als andere.
Jetzt haben wir extrem viel
über Restriktionen,
Gefahren, Einschränkungen gesprochen.
Jetzt möchte ich noch
über etwas sehr Positives
auf der Segelflugkarte sprechen.
Über eine Erleichterung für uns
Gleitschimpiloten.
Und das sind die LSR for Gliders.
Das sind die Segelflugzonen.
Die sind grün eingezeichnet.
Es ist zwar auch LSR,
ist aber nicht für uns restriktiert.
Es ist für Instrumentenflugzeuge
oder Instrumentenflug
Luftfahrzeuge restriktiert.
Und ist deshalb eine Erleichterung für uns,
wo wir näher an die Wolken kommen.
Zu den Wolkenabständen kommen wir
nachher gerne.
Und was das genau bedeutet.
Die LSR sind vom 1. März
bis zum 31. Oktober aktiv.
Auch hier,
passt auf, dass ihr auf diese Zeiten schaut.
Und dass ihr nicht zum Beispiel
an einem super guten Tag im Februar,
kann es ja mal geben,
am Thermikfliegen seid,
und euch aber gar nicht bewusst ist,
ob ihr aktiv seid.
Also passt auf,
dass ihr wirklich erst am 1. März anfangt.
Und auch für die Prüfung,
für die Theorieprüfung,
aber auch für die Theoriefrage an der praktischen Prüfung,
wenn ihr im Winter eure Prüfung absolviert,
kann es sein,
dass der Experte vielleicht eine fiese Frage stellt
zu den Segelflugzonen,
die dann eben noch gerne nicht aktiv sind.
Ausgesehen klingen sie so.
Grün umrahmt.
Auch hier haben wir Unter- und Obergrenzen angegeben
auf der Segelflugkarte.
Wenn wir von diesen LSRs sprechen,
kommen wir zwangsläufig
auch gleich zum Thema Wolkenabstände.
Die Wolkenabstände sind so geregelt,
dass es bis zu 300 Meter
über Grund
keinen Wolkenabstand braucht.
Ihr müsst einfach jederzeit ausserhalb
der Wolke sein und auch
eine Umkehrkurve machen können.
Ihr könnt also nicht frontal auf eine Wolke zufliegen,
bis ihr fast drin seid,
sondern ihr müsst jederzeit umkehren.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Die Sicht in die Horizontalen
muss 1,5 Kilometer sein
und ihr müsst immer am Boden heruntersehen.
Diese Regeln gilt bis auf 300 Meter.
Es ist etwas speziell.
Es wird nicht einfach gesagt,
dass es im Luftraum G ist,
sondern es ist nur die Hälfte des G.
Es sind also nur 300 Meter
und nicht 600 Meter,
wo die Grenze gezogen wird.
Daran müsst ihr auch denken.
Alles, was über 300 Meter ist,
muss nachher ziemlich grosse Wolkenabstände haben.
In den Vertikalen sind es 300 Meter
und in den Horizontalen
1500 Meter Abstand zu den Wolken.
Von der Sicht her sind es
nicht mehr nur 1,5 Kilometer,
sondern es geht dann hier hoch
auf 5 Kilometer,
respektive 8 Kilometer,
sobald wir über 3050 fliegen.
Das hat einfach mit den Geschwindigkeiten
der Flugzeuge zu tun,
weil weiter oben
höhere Geschwindigkeiten geflogen werden
und es braucht natürlich auch mehr Zeit
um zu reagieren und auszuweichen.
Die Flügel fliegen in die Wolken
und wenn sie aus den Wolken rauskommen
und wir nur 500 Meter Abstand haben
zu diesen Wolken,
wird es unter Umständen schon knapp werden.
Darum haben wir
höher oben grössere Wolkenabstände.
Ausser im Spezialfall
der Segelflugzone LSR4 Gliders
sieht es etwas anders aus.
In diesen Zonen
haben wir nämlich
einen minimierten Wolkenabstand.
Das sind 50 Meter vertikal
und 100 Meter horizontal.
Auf der rechten Seite
seht ihr auch wieder
die Untergrenze und die Obergrenze
dieses Luftraums.
Hier ist noch wichtig,
dass ihr euch nicht verwirren lasst
oder denkt,
dass ihr bei 2450
in einem Superthermikschlauch
aufhören und wieder runter fliegen müsst.
Ihr dürft also durchaus
über diese Höhe aussteigen.
Das Einzige, was dann wieder wechselt,
sobald ihr drüber seid,
sind die Wolkenabstände.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel
auf 25 sind,
gilt dann wieder die grossen Wolkenabstände.
Das ist noch wichtig zu wissen
und hat manchmal bei der Theorieprüfung
auch die Fragen so gestellt,
dass man dann vielleicht
zurückkehrt und meint,
man fährt nur auf 255.
Das gilt dann aber nicht fürs Fliegen,
sondern nur für die Wolkenabstände,
die man einhalten muss.
Viele von diesen LSRs
haben hinten keinen Zusatz
und einfach nur die Höhe.
Und gewisse haben
hinten noch einen Zusatz
von MO.
MO heisst, es ist nur aktiv,
wenn das Militär off ist.
Also wenn das Militär
nicht aktiv ist.
Das MA ist auch immer aktiv,
wenn das Militär nicht frei ist.
Beim MA ist der Unterschied,
wenn dort das Militär aktiv ist,
kann es sein,
dass es dann gleich
freigegeben wird.
Wenn das Militär aktiv ist
und MA steht, kann man nachfragen.
Vielleicht öffnet es dann
den Luftraum gleich,
weil das Militär vielleicht
an einem anderen Ort ist
oder den Luftraum nicht benutzt.
Jetzt haben wir ganz viele Theorien gehört.
Ich hoffe,
ihr mögt noch zuhören.
Jetzt kommt es zu einer Theoriefrage.
Als Aufwärmung
für die Theorieprüfung
und natürlich auch
für das Fliegerleben.
Wir stehen auf dem Startplatz
und müssen wissen,
wie hoch ich fliege,
wie sind die Wolkenabstände,
wie weit muss ich sehen
und bin ich legal unterwegs
oder müsste ich es starten?
Lieber Silo.
Grundsätzlich stelle ich mir
immer die fünf Fragen,
wenn ich an einem Punkt bin.
Zum einen ist es die Jahreszeit
wegen der Segelflugzeit.
Bin ich zwischen März und Oktober
oder bin ich im Winter?
Das würde mich in der Segelflugzone beeinflussen.
Das zweite ist der Wochentag
und die Tourzeit
wegen dem Militär,
um zu wissen, wie hoch ich steigen darf,
wenn es super läuft.
Dann muss ich wissen,
bin ich nördlich oder südlich
der Trennlinie?
Bin ich im Mittelland oder in den Alpen?
Die Höhe, die ich gerade im Moment bin,
ist sehr wichtig zu wissen
und auch der Standort.
Befinde ich mich im Radius
in einer Sperrzone.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Wenn ihr euch diese fünf Fragen beantworten könnt,
dann kommt ihr auch
relativ schnell
auf diese Lösung.
Vielleicht könnt ihr schnell Pause drücken
und noch nicht auf die nächste Folie weitergehen
und euch die Aufgabe überlegen.
In der nächsten Folie
kommt gleich die Erklärung dazu.
Ihr seht, es ist Standort B.
Es ist eine maximal hohe Höhe
von 3'050 m,
weil wir nämlich nördlich
in der Trennlinie sind.
Es ist hier etwas fies,
es ist bei der Grenze,
aber leicht oberhalb oder links davon
heisst, wir sind im Mittelland.
Die Antwort mit 4'550 m
kann man eigentlich schon streichen.
Ganz oft kommt man dann,
was die Theorieprüfung anbelangt,
durch das Ausschlussverfahren
auf die richtige Lösung.
Fliegen verboten,
sehe ich hier keinen Grund.
Wir haben keinen Flugplatz,
keinen Heliport in der Nähe.
In der Danger- oder Restricted Area
besser gesagt.
Es sieht alles nach Fliegen aus.
Die Höhe ist
bei B und C gleich hoch.
Jetzt müssen wir herausfinden,
wie ist es mit den Wolkenabständen.
Wir sind ja auf 2'700 m oben.
Das heisst,
die Sicht ist 5 km.
Das sehen wir hier.
Bei den Beinen steht 5 km,
weil wir noch unter den 3'050 m sind.
Höher dürfen wir ja nicht,
weil wir im Mittelland sind.
Was die Wolkenabstände angeht,
müssen wir überlegen,
ob wir in einer Segelflugzone sind oder nicht.
Das ist etwas gemein.
Man könnte meinen,
man ist drinnen.
Aber wenn ihr die Zahlen
beim LSR21 genau anschaut,
gehen die LSR4 Gliders
nur auf 2'450 m hoch.
Wir befinden uns aber schon
in der Luft auf 2'007 m.
Das heisst,
wir sind drüber.
Wir dürfen dort fliegen.
Das ist nicht verboten.
Aber wir müssen leider wieder
die grossen Wolkenabstände,
also 300 m und 1'5 km, einhalten.
So versuche ich euch
damit auf den Weg zu gehen,
nach diesen Kriterien
zu verfahren,
sodass ihr immer legal unterwegs seid
und auch Fragen für Prüfungen
korrekt beantworten könnt.
Dann haben wir hier nochmals
ein kleines Beispiel.
Wir müssen auf alles eingehen.
Hier einfach auch aufpassen.
Wir sehen,
wir sind auf 1'850 m hoch.
Der Luftraum D geht von 1'600 m
bis auf 1'350 m.
Also ist man doch recht schnell verleitet,
zu sagen, das ist verboten.
Da bin ich voll in den Thema.
Fliegen verboten.
Entweder nicht starten,
an der Prüfung Fliegen verboten anklicken
und weitergehen.
Überlegt euch hier nochmals
ganz gut.
Das sind die Sonderregeln,
die uns entgegenkommen.
Wir sind hier in Meiringen.
Es hilft natürlich,
wenn man die Karte ein wenig kennt.
Man ist aber hier südlich von der Linie.
Man ist in den Alpen.
Darum kommt die Sonderregelung
zum Zug,
dass man 300 m unter dem TMH
durchfliegt.
Und wir sind,
wie man hier oben sieht,
auf 150 m über dem Grund
legal unterwegs.
Mit einer Maximalhöhe
von 300 m über dem Grund natürlich.
Hier ist keine Höhe
über dem Meer angegeben,
denn der Grund variiert ja auch.
Wenn wir dem Gelände nachfliegen
und einfach immer die 300 m einhalten,
sind wir also jederzeit legal unterwegs.
Es sind nur 300 m,
darum Wolkenabstand.
Kein Wolkenabstand,
ausserhalb der Wolken fliegen
mit Umkehrkurve jederzeit möglich
und Bodensicht.
Ich möchte mich für eure Aufmerksamkeit bedanken.
Danke fürs Zuhören.
Ich hoffe, ich konnte euch etwas mit auf den Weg geben,
dass ihr in einem ersten Schritt
mal positiv
dran gehen könnt,
euch vorbereiten könnt auf die Prüfung
und dann in einem zweiten Schritt natürlich
ganz viel Spass im Fliegeralltag
und dass ihr jederzeit sicher
und legal im Schweizer Luftraum unterwegs seid.
Vielen Dank.
Bis bald.